hi guys it's been a while I've been
swamped with work as well as putting
together one of my largest videos ever
so I hope you all bear with me while I
get to finished in the gap of uploads
though I really wanted to tell you about
some awesome things that I thought
couldn't wait the biggest thing is that
we hit 100,000 subscribers late February
which is absolutely amazing the same
time last February I had set some goals
for this channel and of all of them the
most ambitious of them was to get to
50,000 subs in one year to really
understand how crazy that goal was to me
at the time first you have to know that
I had a youtube channel before this
making piano videos and it took me 80
videos over two years to get 100
subscribers so zero to 50k in one year
was pretty much shooting for the moon
and even by last July I only had 300
subscribers on this channel so I had
thought that goal was dead in the water
but thanks to you all who watch these
videos and shared them we not only hit
that goal we doubled it you all made
that amazing goal possible so thank you
now I think the question is now that we
have all these people here what are we
gonna do to make this channel even
better
well first we got our subreddit our
slash coffee break one word started on
reddit we don't have many people there
yet but that's about to change and it's
going to eventually become a big part of
this community we already have a discord
which is more like a chatroom but reddit
superior comment sorting makes it better
for group discussion so I want you guys
to go subscribe over there it's going to
be a great place to meet like-minded
people and discuss videos and ideas
it'll also be a place for future
announcements such as the one in this
video secondly I wanted to tell you that
I do a lot of research for these videos
and I want to make that more visible
going forward so I'm gonna be putting
more and more effort into getting good
footnotes for these videos if you want
to learn more about the subjects they
talk about the third thing I can't talk
too much about yet but I plan on
focusing more on coffee break soon if
you look at my backlog I used to upload
once a week but that had slowed down
because of work related stuff that's
gonna change come April or May and we're
gonna try to ramp back up to a more
frequent upload schedule and finally as
part of the 100k celebration I decided
to take this moment to highlight the
lesser-known people behind the show the
musicians whose music I feature on the
channel music has always been huge for
this channel and I'm sure it's part of
the reason a lot of you
like listening to me so I'm gonna be
uploading a best of coffee break music
mix right after this video to
essentially throw a spotlight on just
how talented these people are I'm
uploading it separately from this video
so if you guys want to just put it on
and study music or whatever you don't
have to listen to my annoying preamble
every time but if I could just ask of
you when you go to listen to the music
mix if you like one of the songs please
go check out the artists actual page and
comment telling them you came from
coffee break all the artists I feature
in here are incredible and the songs I
show only scratch the surface
alright that's pretty much it to recap
reddit more videos around April in May
and go check out some of those amazing
artists I feel so blessed to reach 100k
subs in one year and I'm looking forward
to where we go from here thank you for
watching
[Music]
[Applause]